es ist so eine riesen gruppenaufgabe
praktisch also ende wie so eine quest
haid die du immer wieder machen
erkenntnissen und ja das war irgendwie
dann nur arbeit das spiel für mich also
dass ich musste so viel im spiel machen
weil ich halt da um einen status hatte
in der top gilde und in den halb links
und ich musste so viel diesem spiel
machen dass ich das schon als arbeitet
angesehen habe und dann kam ich nach
hause von der schule gestresst wollte
dann weiß zocken und hat irgendwie auch
für das gefühl gehabt ich muss arbeiten
und dann irgendwann habe ich dann so
irgendwie die lust verloren aber es war
also dass ich halt nicht aufhören konnte
gehabt und trotzdem weitergemacht
und dann hat dann mit meiner oma und
meinem opa mit dem fleet öfters im
urlaub dann bin ich halt haben die
gesagt willst du dieses jahr wieder mit
urlaub fliegen zwei wochen in tunesien
war es glaube ich jahr 2008 war es
selber zu lesen ist schon lange her
alles und da habe ich mir gedacht toll
zwei wochen und dem leiter der viacom
koste geld
dadurch geht ob scheiße und so und wie
ich habe ich das zwei wochen so aber da
habe ich irgendwie entschluß gefaßt
kommen urlaub jetzt ist mal was ganz
schön ist so und ich habe den account
eingefroren und man kann viel wert
account einfrieren dann läuft weiter und
dann bin ich ja den urlaub geflogen war
zwei wochen urlaub haben wir gemerkt wie
schön ist es wieder so richtig am leben
teilzunehmen ist alles teil krank andere
und habe dann nach diversen einfach so
ein komplettes soziales opfern der
gesellschaft zeichnen und dann hab ich
den account danach nach dem urlaub
wieder aufgetaut also ich hab ihn immer
auch eingefroren ich träume schon wieder
auf ihren kopf ein spaß also ich hab
noch nie wow oder null angefangen ganz
einfach aus dem grund weil ich halt
angst habe dass es mit mir auch so
ergeht oder und einfach weil ich glaube
dass die spieler alles für mich sind und
das ist ja total cup drin wäre und
seeleute mal bei diesen live streams
oder auch bei youtube videos teilweise
aber
das ist gar nichts für mich so wie ich
bin eigentlich schon jetzt herzlich
spiele allgemeinen jetzt gar nicht mehr
seitdem das komische namen seitdem das
mit dem mittweida passiert ist oder so
ich stelle das jetzt auch so total
schrecklich was bei mir jetzt eigentlich
aber eigentlich fast gar nicht und ich
glaube ich bin eigentlich ganz zufrieden
so wie es zurzeit bei mir aber ich
schaffe das mit der schule alles und mit
youtube unter einen hut zu bringen und
vor allem wenn man das was einem spaß
macht sag ich mal wenn man damit geld
verdienen kann es ist immer so eine
sache es gibt ja dieses zitat sind gut
wenn du gut in etwas bist mach es die
kostenlose wegen sowas natürlich scheiße
an
ich weiß nicht was sie tat hier in dem
zusammenhang bringt ich finde das ganz
cool dass wir zocken und das hochladen
dass sie das wörther angucken das finde
ich cool dass wir quasi was zurück
bekommen dafür dass wir zocken
dieses gefühl sage ich mal dafür möchte
ich einfach mal alle von euch danken die
gerade dieses video schauen also sich
auch richtig also deswegen auch wenn ihr
auch dahin spaß findet also wie gesagt
hab dann nachdem erst
nachdem er nach dieser erfahrung halten
konnte auf gefroren bin in dieses ts
begangen von mir von meiner ganzen
frenster und so oft gesagt so ich spiele
kein wow mehr sorry ich bin jetzt weg
ist ungeheuer und so ich habe das ist
das einzige was jetzt gerade meine
situation das richtige ist so weil ich
jetzt als die schule fertig verpackt und
alles und jetzt mit meiner ausbildung
fast fertig und alles so richtig gut
gemacht und so also ich bin richtig froh
das ist alles jetzt doch noch geklappt
hat weil wirklich an der grenze dass ich
gedacht habe ich schaffe es nicht mehr
weil ich wirklich einfach auch kein bock
mehr ich habe nicht wirklich nichts
getan und jetzt habe ich dann halt
danach diese extreme zopf unlust und so
und jetzt habe ich natürlich dass also
genau der punkt was ich sagen will was
mich eigentlich davon weg gebracht hat
ist immer diese leistung die man ins
spiel bringen muss natürlich ist im
spiel auch auf einer seite den wettkampf
klar und bei möchten messen in den
meisten spielen ist man sich damit
allein
irgendwas misst man da also habe ich mal
meinen gehören zu fall der am besten
bauer und karl oder baykal beide meisten
kramer dies und das irgendwo misst man
sich ja immer mit anderen den spielen
des spiels aber irgendwo im wettkampf
aber ich habe zum beispiel nach über der
vorschrift habe ich noch halt starcraft
2 gespielt und so und das ist auch wie
ein spiel wo du wirklich die ganze zeit
voll fall alles geben muss also stark
und spielt nun die ganze zeit die ganze
zeit trug die haftzeit die ganze zeit
moderne sitze hätte wo man sich auch
wirklich entspannen kann das ist kein
spiel wo ich mich entspannen kann also
und dann ich habe auch noch selbst
bisher aktiv counterstrike und zuspieler
so spiele wo du auch wirklich er hat
einen skill die ganze zeit teilt ja
einsetzen muss und so und minecraft ich
muss euch sein weil oft ist wirklich
eine wohltat also ohne liebe dieses
spiel kannst es hätte mich auch so galt
deswegen mache ich das auch du kannst
einen hab hier ein bisschen was ab und
einfach dazu quatschen über ein thema
und du kannst einfach chillen dabei
finde ich das ist das coole ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen minecraft aber ich
liebe dieses spiel fast so simpel ist
also es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie der
sitzung die planung ist meist simpel
nichts schlechtes sondern gerade das das
simple es ja oft das gute und minecraft
es so simpel und dass man kann mit so
wenig also es kann eigentlich jeder das
spiel spielen das kann euch bei
starcraft oder so nichts sagen sagt zum
beispiel da sagt man ok zehn prozent der
menschen
die das spiel kaufen können sie
überhaupt spielen weil das braucht
wirklich skill und so aber minecraft das
ist ein spiel das kann jeder schnell
lernt da kann man halt auch nicht
irgendwo der über killer sein oder so
weil das pvp in mainz auch sehr simpel
gehalten man schlägt hätten beschwert
drauf und mal klick hat die maus ganz
schnell das war's also nach microsoft
kein spiel wohl uhr über das killer sein
muss und es tut mir auch leid alle leute
die für pvp profis halten
in minecraft müsst ihr euch nicht
einwählen wenn ihr irgendwelche pvp
profis also ist einfach so und deswegen
liebe ich das spiel weil das spiel
einfach keine anforderung stellt also
keine anforderung die dich irgendwie ja
so fertigmachen du brauchst eine
komplette spieler leitung durchzulesen
um das spiel zu kapieren sage ich mal
bis auf den sommer ein minuten weiß also
du weißt zwar nicht alles direkt aber du
kommst auf jeden fall ist mal klar man
muss sich alles geben diese spielt also
man kann das spiel einfach wirklich
spielen also ein spiel ist einfach für
mich eine beschäftigung um eine zeit
einfach spaß sich zu verbringen
und deswegen ist zeitverschwendung weil
seinerzeit ja ich habe mal mit freude zu
nutzt also das was man was einem spaß
macht in seiner freizeit zu machen ist
keine zeitverschwendung weil wenn man
spaß hat es nie zeitverschwendung und
mir macht es einfach aus dem grund
einfach riesenspaß und gerade dass ich
jetzt noch diese chance habe hier die
hatte let's play zu machen und eine
zuschauerschaft habe und die sich dafür
in tritt und so also das ist einfach es
ist sehr steigert das ganz normal wenn
man weiß dass wir noch vor allem diese
sache wenn man das kann ich jetzt aber
darauf beziehen wenn man auf server
kommt zum beispiel und alle kennen ein
also ist das problem ein wir bei uns ist
natürlich auf der einen seite total
kacke wenn wir wenn wir uns dann alle
töten oder so aber andererseits heißt es
ja die wollen irgendwie dass wir sie
sehen und die finden dass er auch
irgendwie geil dass wir dann bei denen
da auf dem server sind und das heißt wir
haben eine gewisse ich sag mal nicht
vorbildfunktion sondern die mögen uns
sehen wir sehen uns halt schon ein
bisschen so als
ja vorbild hat eigentlich schon
getroffen aber ich finde eigentlich ganz
cool dass man diesen bekanntheitsgrad
beziehungsweise bekannter täter nicht
genießen darf dass wir das dürfen weil
der das blog dass diese diese das können
ja nicht viele so es gibt ja nicht viele
die jetzt ist er total schwer so was zu
erlangen hat gerade als player also man
hört ja einfach wie viele es gibt und
unter jedem video legt der schaum auf
meinem kanal vorbei
vielleicht auch gerade angefangen so es
gibt ja ich weiss nicht also dass ich da
etwas was am youtube am meisten gibt es
jetzt auf jeden fall lösen so also so
beschwingt gurus und let's play und
davon gibt's einfach so viele es einfach
so schwer ist überhaupt da irgendwo mal
einen gewissen bekanntheitsgrad zu
erreichen also ich habe ja auch mit
beflockt videos angefangen auf youtube
und ich habe auf mein haupt also auf
einem kanal unschwer hab ich ja schon
14.000 abonnenten und so
dadurch habe ich diesen einstieg erst
mal in dieser community hier in diese
letzte community einfachen geschafft und
ich bin so froh dass ich jetzt die sind
jetzt kann er angefangen habe weil das
jetzt auf mein haupt kanal und liebe
dies also ich liebe diesen kanal einfach
über alles weil ich hatte noch nie so
viel spaß an youtube stadt noch nie so
viel spaß am zocken also ich bin
wirklich einfach nur rund um richtig
glücklich also kann man gar nicht
beschreiben das wochen
ich wollte ich gar nichts mehr sage ich
wollte nur sagen dass ich jetzt blöd von
mir damals fand mit minecraft
einzufangen welcher wert kanal kontrakt
ich habe immer nur minecraft machte
letztens habe ich mal mit fifa
angefangen und ich habe schon mal damals
habe ich gespielt
gegen spiel habe ich noch gespielt was
halt nicht minecraft war und da meinten
alle drunter ja richtig dass minecraft
kanal wird alle daumen runter gegeben
das war total doof und dann hat das
natürlich spaß macht das so zu werden
kann ich damit wieder aufgehört habe
dann mit minecraft so weitergemacht
ich bin auch zufrieden dass ich meine
kraft hauptsächlich machen uhr es ist
halt wirklich alle leute sind hier wegen
minecraft das weiß man und deswegen
frage promo der zombie hat eine axt in
hand eine schaufel deswegen frage ich
mich immer so reformiert weg deswegen
frage ich mich wirklich immer so
warum sind die leute jetzt eigentlich
hier nur weil setzt minecraft sehen
wollen oder wegen mir oder gar keine
ahnung jedenfalls finde ich aber ganz
gut dass die leute bei mir jetzt damals
ich habe jetzt andere von fifa
hochzuladen
ja da kommen bald neue partner ich muss
da immer wenn in zum fernseher um räume
auf dem tisch wegen dieser blöden elgato
game capture card nur wasser freigesetzt
ich darf sogar im spiel nach meinem
spiel mit ein bisschen minecraft jetzt
also es ist so ein spieler ist ein
schatz darin mütter pixelgrafik spiel
nur wow ja ich auch nein also hat sich
eigentlich alles ganz cool entwickelt
finde ich finde ich alles richtig so und
jetzt haben wir ungefähr ich denke
locker 30 minuten über das thema
gequatscht aber ich denke mal wenn mein
team hat mir darüber lange reden kann
das ist auch ein thema aus beide
parteien ist uns beide vielleicht
interessiert und wir haben ja auch
eigene erfahrungen die wir uns da sehr
sehr gut schildern konnten und ich kann
auch gut vorstellen dass man spannendes
zu hören was wir so für gaming erfahrung
gemacht haben also generell wenn jetzt
bis hierhin die folgen durch haut habt
und ihr habt alle folgen vorher geschaut
um unsere komplette diskussion über
gaming gehört schreibt einfach meine
kommentare wie euer ja euer leben durch
gaming irgendwie vater war einst jetzt
was habt ihr also ihr seid ja alles ich
sag mal die leute die hier gucken sie
wahrscheinlich alles gamer
es gibt jetzt kann man da so sei sie ja
also gamer heißt jetzt nicht unbedingt
das wird übel sondern dass man einfach
sagt susanne bock hat das macht ja fast
jeder einfach und deswegen werden
deswegen werden wir und erzählt einfach
mal vielleicht habt ihr auch negative
vor sie was hat euch schon mal wissen
dass sie für eine höhle ist ein schaf
und einer höhle nicht meine rang ich
würde einfach interessieren was die
zuschauer so ja ob sie jetzt mal durch
scale flechter freunde kennengelernt
haben oder vielleicht auch mal dadurch
schule verpackt haben ja wiederholt
haben so ist man kann eher negativ und
soweit auch positiver form machen und
morgen gehen egal ob kurz zum haus so
rüdiger horn
du hast heraus gesetzes freute ich mich
nicht habe ich das gemacht so nett wenn
man das ding ist